so before andreas starts it just like to
remind everybody we're gonna after these
two talks we're gonna have a discussion
session and so this is a little time you
can prepare your three-minute burning
question if you want to help us get
started the discussion so next up is and
research Thanks thanks for the
invitation and in some way I think
you'll you'll see that grid cells are
much simpler then you may have thought
and on the other hand I'll also try to
indicate that some phenomena are much
more complicated than we think
so at the end you're probably where you
are right now all right and I should
mention that I do so right ahead
that it's mainly Burk of Martin Center
and Alexander mattis Alexander was a PhD
student in the group and Martin is a
senior research affiliate and I changed
the title a little bit to reflect these
issues so we heard already from Mike
quite a lot about grid cells
unfortunately he didn't show this slide
so I have to do it for those that are
not in neuroscience yet so if we record
in internal cortex with an extracellular
electrode you will get signals from
multiple neurons and so these are again
these firing fields if you mark the
Centers of the firing fields in this
case from these three cells with crosses
it's still a bit confusing but if you
move all green crosses and all blue
crosses relative to the red crosses you
can get them in this shape which means
as you had only moved them not rotated
not scaled then at least nearby grid
cells have similar spatial frequency
similar orientation but a different
spatial phase so that's one key property
of grid cells and the other is that the
spatial scale it changes and in fact it
increases when you go from dorsal to
ventral so you see clearly they're
different grid scale
and in fact it does not do so in a
continuous manner but stepwise and the
sequence of scales forms a geometric
series these are the main properties of
grid cells I'll be basing the talk on
there many more but these are like the
core ingredients that you should know
and that also means that in the end we
can talk about grid modules so within
each module cells obey these properties
and there are somewhere between 4 and 10
modules this number is not settled
because it's difficult to record ones
end of the grid cell area and therefore
maybe it's four maybe it's six probably
it's not ten but somewhere in this range
I will not talk today about mechanisms
this would be an entirely different talk
and there are people in the audience
like U of M and ela that have worked
extensively and all the mic on the
various models I will not go into
mechanisms there are these two different
main classes of models and one reason
why it will not go into that because I
want to focus on decoding and because
neither of the two model classes
explains why there is too stepwise
increase in grid scale sitting in
different sub parts of the entorhinal
cortex but one should be careful there
even intermingled regions will you get
different scales at the same location so
what I want to focus on is the reason
why the Moses got the Nobel Prize some
years ago and it was given to them
because the grid since the grid system
provides a solution to measuring
movement distances and adds a metric to
the spatial maps and hippocampus an
internal GPS the last part is certainly
for PR reasons nobody believes that
there is a GPS in our brain but there's
still this notion and you could also
hear that in some of the talks this more
that grid cells clearly offer a metric
and I'd like to question that so is it
really a metric for space and in which
sense is it so the usual argument goes
such that each cell has periodically
laid out firing fields and so for
example if you go along that route you
will have increases and decreases or
firing rate and if you know for how long
you have gone then this allows you to
measure distances beautiful picture
however nobody tells the ret to move
along straight lines that go directly
through adjacent centers so if the ret
happens to go that way or that way it
would see a different effective scale
and therefore measure with a different
measuring device one meter would not be
one meter anymore if there were only
grid cells sure enough if the red has
also access to directional information
we heard about head Direction cells
earlier it can put this information
together and compute distances but using
grid cells alone its difficulty using a
grid cell alone I should say and in fact
nobody tells the animal to move along
straight lines it could also go in
circles come back to the same position
have the same firing pattern but not
moved at all so what can we say if you
go on and speak about spatial location
whether grid cell system can be used to
do that then you run into the following
question and I have done it in a like
idealized form these are three grid
cells and they have aligned orientation
similar grid scale but there is a
spatial phase shift that's grid cells
within one module and you may wonder why
are they arranged in that way because
obviously because they repeat
periodically the readout does not know
whether the animal is here or one period
away there is no information in this
periodically repeating pattern and
that's slightly puzzling because if the
grid fields of different
cells within one module were rotated
with respect to each other every
position in space could correspond
uniquely to a population firing pattern
of the grid cells and then one could
decode space relatively easily so one of
the questions I want to address is why
are the XS aligned within a module and
there is a simple answer to that if you
believe in continuous attractor models
because they're all neurons are living
in the same activation sheet and
necessarily have aligned directions
however from a decoding point of view
that doesn't answer this question so I'd
like to understand does it make sense
from a coding - decoding point of view
to have an arrangement like that which
at first sight seems not to be ideal and
in order to address these questions we
have to think about what does it mean to
encode what does it mean to decode and
so you think about two healthy
populations by count within some spike
account window the whole population and
neurons and their spike counts from the
first to the end neuron are given by
some probability of generating this
population spike count given the
position of the animal that would be our
encoding model and the decoding would
mean that the animal or we as people
analyzing the data are asking what is
the most likely position x given the
spike count vector at that particular
point so these two probabilities are
related by Bayes rule and therefore you
can under certain assumptions that
simplify the whole game and I will make
these assumptions that are independent
Poisson spike trains that there is a
flat prior and that are sufficiently
many neurons such that a particular term
the sum over the firing fields as a
function of X that this is called
as a function of X this property is in
fact fulfilled or roughly fulfilled with
10 or 20 neurons per module so that's
not a real tough assumption the flat
prior might be stronger 1 and assuming
independent Poisson spike trains is
certainly not doing a fair job to
reality as I'll point out at the very
end of the talk so if you put all these
equations into that you find that the
posterior is given by this formula which
is compact yet it's still complicated
how should the animal if it wants to
read out its position from the spike
train pattern of the grid cells how can
it calculate this maximum because that's
the most likely position given the spike
count vector we can do it and in fact
when people run decoding algorithms and
they do Bayesian decoding they do
something similar then go through all
possible positions X a square is the
highest possibility where's the highest
probability and that's the decoded
position but how could the animal do
that how could the animal compute this
horrible emotional feelings to
mathematics this horrible term and I
will argue that under certain conditions
this can be done very easily and we
believe that the grid cell system can
actually do that and one Avenue towards
answering this question comes from
analyzing what the firing field actually
the firing field profile looks like and
if you do so you see that it can be bell
fit by what's called a fan Mises journey
that's a cosine in the exponent of an
exponential function and putting the
cosine up here and multiplying it by
what's called the concentration
parameter allows you to scale the widths
of the grid field while keeping the
period constant so unlike a sine or
cosine where the width
defined by the wavelengths you have an
additional freedom in fact these tuning
curves can be found in many other
systems quite often people for example
motor cortex they speak about sine or
cosine tuning in fact if they fitted the
curves with a fan missus they get much
better results so fan missus tuning is
not only a mathematical hack but it
seems to really capture the firing
properties of a whole range of neurons
motor cortex visual cortex thalamus
they're all nicely fit by some Mises
tuning curves but there is more to that
and that was the insight Martin had and
I think it's the inside of a
mathematician or somebody trained in
theoretical physics that you would never
get if you are simply doing numerical
calculations so what Martin realized is
that if you have a missus tuning then
the posterior which was this horrible
sum if you put in these terms it is also
fun Mises talking about 1d but we can
extend this to higher dimensions and
that means that the maximum of the fan
Mises can be calculated as a population
vector similarly to population vectors
that have been calculated in the motor
system and I want to show you how that
actually works graphically let's assume
that the poor rat dormouse is sitting at
a certain position we have for example
20 grid cells they fire with particular
firing rates or spike count in a certain
window and now what that means is that
you arrange these spike counts around a
circle and you calculate the population
vector project this back and you'll get
the most likely position and from the
spread you also get information about
how likely certain deviations from this
most likely positions are
to do that the requirement is that you
can put all these neural tuning curves
on the same circle and that means that
it only works if all neurons within one
module have the same wavelength so that
explains or provides an explanation why
within one module we really want to have
the same grid scale that's in 1d and if
you extend the argument to 2d it means
that the directions have to be aligned
because if they are not aligned you'll
get if you project to the X or Y axis
you would get different circumferences
and then it would not work population
back to decoding so the argument goes as
follows
if you want to do population vector
decoding you'd better have grid cells
arranged such that they fall into
classes with aligned orientations and
identical periods yes next slide next
slide
anyway so was it so it sort of doesn't
seem to matter whether well if I had if
I have one module with a certain
wavelength right I run this algorithm I
get a certain position estimate that
comes with an error and then I use the
next one to refine this estimate not
using population vector at max yes but
not this construction the middle thing
holds if you have fun meters well if you
put in the fan meter so okay right yeah
no what I what I try to argue that if
you have that you can calculate it with
this kind of trick because I would argue
that this is doable if you have some
sine and cosine wave carriers and you
multiply them by the spike count you can
actually calculate that no this is in 1d
now and we would if you go to higher
dimensions we would do it along for
example rectangular coordinates well I
mean I'm not going into this argument
whether it's easy or not what I'm going
into is that if we were able to do that
and people have argued like in the motor
system that this is possible then this
is an approach I can follow is
essentially just a weighted sum of
activities weighted with their jump well
peanuts pointers that you have to do on
this really
the complicated optimization problem
right well Peters argument is that here
you have to do an arctangent question is
where the neurons can do an arc
tangentially or one of your points but
let's talk about this later because
otherwise you will kill me
so the point that would be that we can
refine this estimates and come to very
precise position estimates by refining
step by step now what falls out of that
argument is all the following why should
they be a scale ratio and I didn't say
that before grid scales are have a ratio
the length scale of around 1.5 depending
on the lab it's one point for one point
six but somewhere around one point five
why this magic number why does it help
if you have a single module then the
posterior would have a certain width and
you would know if you are at zero yes
the most likely position is here but
there is a certain deviation possible
now if you add a second module depending
on the scale of the second module you
will for example for s equals two and s
equals 1.5 you would have two situations
let me use this first in this case the
probability to make the right judgment
increases the probability of making a
wrong judgment decreases so that's fine
the second module helps you if on the
other hand the wavelength of the second
module is too small then you get these
side bands and that means that the
probability of making a drastic error in
your position estimate suddenly
increases you're doing much better here
to correct estimate but you also get
these errors from making large this
errors for making large misjudgments in
your position estimate so that seems
that if we stick somewhere around 1.5 we
don't run into this problem so it's
preferential to have such a scale ratio
that does not depend on the Kappa
because what I plot here is a posterior
of the entire population so we would
predict it as should be around 1.5 or
smaller and that depending on whether
now for an experimental prediction
whether you silenced a small-scale
module or some intermediate module you
should get very different behavioral
results if we just silence the smallest
module then resolution decreases if we
silence some intermediate module then
the remaining scale factor if this was
one point five and one point five then
and we silence this module then this
scale factor would be beyond two which
would not be a good situation so then we
would expect that the animal makes
different errors then if we could
silence the smaller scale module and
there is one more advantage from mapping
linear space onto a circle which I try
to demonstrate here so far we have been
talking about allocentric location with
respect to a certain origin and I'd like
to propose a framework that is somewhat
complementary to what you have shown
Mike before I believe that this periodic
representation allows us to have a way
to go from allocentric to e egocentric
coordinates in the following way let us
assume that we want to know what the
animal wants to know the distance to
some food source then what it has to do
or what they could do is if it shifted
the origin from this position to that
one then its allocentric coordinates in
this new coordinate system is exactly
the distance to the food source so the
question then is how can it move the
origin and moving the origin in a the
spatial system is the same as rotating
the origin in the circular arrangement
and now rotating this population vector
corresponds to multiplying these
activities with sine or cosine gratings
now Peter will raise his hand again
and say well we don't know how to do
that yeah and I do agree I put forward
this as a mechanism but it could be
implemented if we had some sine or
cosine waves downstream that add into
the synaptic couplings of neurons
downstream of the grittier population so
finally I come to stuff that is not our
work but that gives a certain twist to
this very simple story I present it to
you namely that the grid patterns are
not always beautiful they are not always
beautifully hexagonal as you can see
here on the data from stem Sola where
clearly there are some deformations and
even stronger in the paper from Julia
Cooper at all you see that here's the
same cell in a quadratic environment
here it's in a trapezoidal one and there
is no beautiful hexagons allottee
anymore and in fact this result led them
to claim that these results challenge
the idea that the grid cell system can
act as a universal spatial metric for
the cognitive map as bread patterns
change markedly between and closes and
even within the same enclosure so here
they argue that because the hexagonal
firing pattern is gone in such in closer
it cannot be a metric and I think what
they got wrong is that they equated 1 to
1 the firing pattern with a metric and
if you think about the globe we happily
live on locally we can do nice Cartesian
coordinate systems but when we get close
to the globe to the pole things get
messy nevertheless there is still a
metric so just having a situation where
you have distorted grid fields does not
imply that the metric is gone and in
fact what we could show is that it's
still all ok if the distortions are
shared from neuron to neuron so they can
be positioned dependent distortions and
as long as they are the same for all
neurons within a module then you can
have a
we doubt that is not affected by these
distortions and Julia was in Munich just
a few days ago they have new results
that are in press that in fact shows
that the distortions are shared between
neurons from the same module well they
they show that this is also the case we
would not and have you seen the paper no
no in this new result no they say it's
the same it's the same yeah let's wait
until the paper is out before our
decoding it doesn't matter because we do
the population vector decoding module by
module we have to text it but it doesn't
kill the algorithm the algorithm would
be killed immediately if the distortion
was different within a module okay and
then sure enough the the picture that
I've drawn so far although it is
incorrect as the grid is not as nice as
you might have thought that is by donut
island also is macaw Fidel that show
that the hexagonal pattern is not always
such that the firing rate Maxima are
identical it may still be hexagonal but
fine great modulations so the simplified
picture where all firing fields are
equal probably does not hold this is not
a killer however for the population
vector decoding if there are
sufficiently many cells whose deviations
from the perfect hexagon are randomly
distributed then you can still add some
over the different cells and effectively
come back to the situation with the
population vector decoding mike has
already pointed out that there is sita
and sita face and there is also face
precession in internal grid cells
and we had looked at that in quite some
detail and asked in particular the
question if you have two firing fields
and you have spikes in one field and
spikes in the next field is there any
relation is there any dependence on
whether a particular grid cell fires
late in one field will it fire late in
the next field and you can analyze all
kinds of things last spike first spike
and what have you and the result was
that there is no correlation and in fact
according to statistics statistical test
unit they are independently encoding the
different firing fields which means that
also from a face precession point of
view grid cells have multiple firing
fields that act as independent encoders
of physical space more to be expected
grid cells do not only encode space but
also the contextual information and let
me finally come back to this movie a
similar one so that is by Dori Derek
Mann similar to what mike has shown you
in there this is just the last slides
and what I want to point out and spikes
are marked with these white diamonds and
if you look at them you'll see that the
way how we describe grid cell activity
by firing fields that implicitly assumes
that you have pores on spike trains that
you can even talk about a nice firing
field probably doesn't hold because
you'll see these streaks of action
potentials they clearly show that the
individual spikes are not independently
drawn from some distribution described
by the firing field so I think yes and
that's was what I tried to get across
today yes there is some regularity in
the grid field firing pattern that may
be used to readout position but no there
is still a lot of features hidden in
these firing patterns that we have no
clue about
what they really mean and what we need
to do and Yoram has done I think a great
step forward in this direction we also
have to get away from decoding location
but remember the animal is moving and so
in the end what we need to do is we have
to think about ways to decode the
movement pattern the trajectory and not
as we have done in many others to decode
location time slice by time slice this
is not a population code combination
right you have a position estimate on
each level and you can use this to
refine on the next level I can show you
the math so is is there a reason to
think that the downstream structures
decode each module independently and
have this problem or you or do they just
does the downstream get the information
from the different scales and then I
think as you were saying the problem and
it goes away right and the original thin
paper before they knew they were grid
cells but they had the multiple fields
they actually did this to standard
decoding analysis and they were able to
reconstruct the animal position very
with high accuracy so I'm just so he
would say having these different modules
may also buy you additional ways of
encoding because maybe the problem of
decoding grid cell activity because of
the multiple firing fields is only a
superficial problem if you knew at some
point where you are and you know that
you cannot jump
then information from one module will
all do the job it's only when you stop
moving and Roetzel activity vanishes
that you don't know whether you're here
or one grid position or two great
positions upwards what I want to say you
can decode beautifully if you give a
start point and then use the grid cell
activity within one module because then
you don't have the ambiguity that can
only arise if you either don't know your
starting position or if you allow for
chumps ambiguous code as long as you
don't leave the range where you have
clear decoding we have one-to-one
decoding there's no problem so if you
move along a closed trajectory you
always know where you are even if you
have a code that repeats periodically
that's absolutely right
yeah I could be in any one of these
places but prior to them here yeah
absolutely right now now I just wanted
to point out that the difficulties of
decoding grid cells may go away as long
as you know your starting point however
if the animal decides to stop which you
know how will the information about this
location be carried
[Applause]
firing